- It is truly a genius of a creation.
I'm going to take my first bite.
Wow, that rice, it's
like a combination of a
rice and omelet.
What's up everyone, it's Mark Wiens with
migrationology.com in Jakarta, Indonesia.
It is mid morning and Ying
and I are walking over
to Glodok, which is Jakarta's Chinatown.
And actually, we don't
really have any plans
of what we're gonna do there, not really,
but we're just gonna walk around, explore,
probably find some street food.
There's a lot of traffic,
as usual, on this road,
so that's why we are walking.
We're going to beat the traffic and we're
gonna explore Jakarta's Chinatown.
We took the back way to get to Chinatown,
through the back streets,
but we are definitely in Chinatown now.
The whole, it's still Jakarta, but you can
definitely feel that it's Chinatown.
We passed a couple of
Chinese temples already,
and you can see some of
the old Chinese buildings
that are evidence that
we are in Chinatown,
as well as, I think
we're gonna walk through
a market soon, I've seen some
people carrying lots of bags.
And also, in Chinatown, they
also have bicycle rickshaws
which are available for transportation.
We have gotten to the
market section of Glodok.
There is a lot of beautiful
looking fruits and vegetables.
And actually, this Chinatown
kinda reminds me of
Bangkok's Chinatown, Yaowarat,
very, a lot of similarities.
And it's a very tight, and busy place.
A lot of business and commerce and
markets everywhere you look.
We just took a turn down a side alley,
this is just a walking alley,
and we are in route to
a famous coffee shop.
I think it's somewhere down
here and maybe to the right.
The market street is a
really great atmosphere,
but then when you get down
on these even side alleys,
it's really quiet back
here and really nice.
A lot of people are very friendly,
and there are lots of
random things for sale.
Just look at this quantity of avocados.
We're just walking through the alley,
we haven't made it to the coffee shop yet,
but I saw a guy selling
siomay from his motorbike.
He had a variety of different
things in his steamer,
and we kind of just chose a
number of different things.
I think these are the actual
siomay and then there's
some tofu and then he also
had one with bitter melon.
I think pork stuffed into bitter melon so
I got one of those.
And then this is definitely
a Chinese style of a dish,
but what really makes it
Indonesian is that they
serve it with peanut sauce.
So, after he finished slicing them all up,
he put a big scoop of
peanut sauce and then
he squeezed on some kecap
manis which is sweet soy sauce.
And I think that's kind of a
chili sauce on the side there.
So, I'm gonna try one of these first.
Dip it into the peanut sauce.
Wow, that has a very
squishy kind of texture.
Almost like mochi glutinous
rice texture to it.
And then at the tail end of my bite,
then I can taste some sesame oil and maybe
a little bit of minced pork.
That's just a straight
up piece of tofu with the
sweet peanut sauce and a little bit of
chili in there as well.
I really love bitter melon, it has such a
wonderful bitter flavor.
And then it's juicy and has a,
like a cucumber crispness to it.
(inaudible)
As I was eating that plate of siomay I was
standing right across the street from a
vegetarian restaurant and
the owner here is really nice
and he invited us to try some of his all
vegetarian Indonesian food.
And what I really want to taste,
I think I'm just going
to get a small taste,
because we might have a lot of,
So, he has a whole spread of
different Indonesian dishes
all vegetarian and the one
that I really want to taste
is rendang which is one of
the most famous Indonesian
dishes and it happens to
be a favorite of mine,
as well, but I have never had
a vegetarian version of it.
I didn't want to order a
whole plate of food with rice
because I think we
still have a lot to eat,
so I just got some of
the rendang to taste it.
This is the rendang vegetarian.
What is in the rendang?
- Mushroom, we make it out
of mushroom, black mushroom.
- I could have a mistaken it for chunks
of meat definitely.
Even on the inside it
looks kind of like meat.
That looks like a big meatball.
That's really good, oh wow.
It's like meat but it's more tender.
It almost tastes like pulled beef,
but that is all mushroom.
That rendang is delicious actually.
It's a little bit spicy,
you can taste the coconut,
and these are some kind
of spring roll types of
things and he said it might taste a
little bit like shrimp.
I think that's bean curd.
That's awesome.
That is my kind of
vegetarian bite right there,
just solid mushrooms, it's
like compressed mushrooms.
That was impressively good,
especially that rendang.
And, so, if you're looking
for all vegetarian food
in Jakarta in Chinatown,
it's right in this lane.
And I'm not sure the name of this lane,
but that was really good vegetarian food.
We finally made it to the
famous, legendary coffee shop.
This place is called Kopi Es Tak Kie.
It is an old school Chinese
Indonesian coffee shop.
And it has a lot of history to it,
if you look around you
can see a lot of photos
on the wall and a lot of
famous people, I believe,
have come here for coffee.
It's really humid and I
decided it would be a good
idea to order a hot coffee.
Oh, that is a good black cup of coffee.
The coffee is so smooth.
And I get it sugarless, so it's just
straight up black coffee,
but really smooth.
It doesn't have much acid,
and just a good, clean
chocolatey flavor.
And this an indoor coffee
shop and they have a
number of different street
food stalls that set up
right outside the door of this shop,
and so you can order street food and then
they will deliver it inside so you can sit
down at the table as long
as you're ordering drinks
and eat the street food from outside.
And one of the options
right outside the door
is Nasi campur and Nasi campur is actually
just means rice and mixed everything.
There's some crispy pork
belly, I think that's gizzard.
This is like boiled chicken.
There's a tiny sliver of an egg.
I think this is the char
siu, the roast pork,
the roasted barbecue pork.
That's a lot more
flavorful than it looked.
That rice is really good.
And then that pork is very lean and
it's actually quite tender.
But I think it would be
improved with some of this
chili sauce, let me add that over here.
And that's a little piece of pork belly.
And I think that is
gizzard, looks like gizzard.
That's like a sour, salty chili sauce.
And then that's definitely gizzard,
it has a very crisp texture to it.
And then actually I don't
think that was pork belly,
I think it might have been chicken,
maybe with a roasted skin.
Chase that with some of this soup,
and there's a vegetable in it as well.
It's a very plain, but very salty soup.
And that vegetable is a
little bit sour, vinegary,
so I think it's a pickled mustard green or
something like that.
Dip it into the sauce, that's like sausage
wrapped around the skewer.
Okay, it's pretty sweet.
That was a good coffee break stop and
another plate of food and
now we are just walking
back down the alley.
There are so many different
choices of foods to
eat within this alley.
We took a little walk down the road
and they have a lot of street food carts
and so I spotted a snack
that I wanted to try.
It is, there are a lot
of different variations
of this that I've seen
all over Southeast Asia.
It's very similar in
cooking style method to a
Sri Lankan hopper, but
it's cooked in a little
personalized rounded
skillet and what he does,
the batter is green.
What he does is, he scoops in some batter,
kinda sloshes it around and then it cooks.
He puts the lid on and
then it cooks so that
the edges are crispy
and then in the center
it's kind of fluffy and
kind of like waffle-like.
The edges are crispy all the way.
And then the inside is
kind of sticky, gooey.
It's sweet and I'm not
sure but I think the
fragrance might be pandan
because of that greeness.
And it sort of has a very
light, vanilla-y essence.
That's a very simple, but kind
of tasty sweet pancake snack.
One of the most common
types of street food
that you'll find in Jakarta
are deep fried items.
And, so, all over the street
you'll find carts with a big
wok full of oil deep frying,
an assortment of different
things and so for our next
street food snack I
just ordered a couple of
deep fried items.
The first thing I got is
a pisang goreng which is
a deep fried banana.
He took the banana and
he kind of sliced it,
but then kept the banana
all together and kind of
made it into a finger/hand shape.
It's almost like a little glove mitt.
How he cut it like this,
in strips but keeping
the whole thing together, it
gives it more surface area
for more crunchy batter and I think it's a
pretty cool way to cut a
banana for deep frying it.
That is quite a lot of batter.
And it's very crispy
and then there's kind of
a lot of batter to banana ratio,
but then on the inside is the very sweet
and kinda custard-y banana.
It's like a little banana sandwich.
For many of my growing up
years, I lived in Africa,
in central Africa.
And when my family was
living in the Democratic
Republic of Congo, I used to
eat breadfruit all the time.
But then, since I was
a child I haven't had
breadfruit very often
and even where I live
in Thailand, in Bangkok, breadfruit is
not very common at all, actually.
You can see sometimes
on the tree, but it's
very rarely eaten.
So, I was happy to see he
has deep fried breadfruit.
This is just a big slice
of breadfruit deep fried.
That brings back some great memories.
Breadfruit is awesome.
This is just a natural
phenomena of a fruit.
It is really like a very
starchy, starchy bread.
Kinda like a cross
between bread and potato.
Actually kinda like cassava.
It has that really dry starchiness to it
and then this one is just
really nicely salted, as well.
So, it's like a salty,
silky, bread-y, potato.
And then it does have a little
bit of a fruity taste to it.
But that's really heavy.
I think partly why I like
this so much is because
I grew up, when I was a kid, eating this
and I have so many memories of breadfruit.
That is such a starchy,
it's delicious actually.
I really like it.
It's very heavy and dry.
Chinatown's around the
world in different cities
are one of my favorite places to explore.
And Chinatown here in
Jakarta has been great.
There's a lot of food and a
lot of cool places to explore.
If you just kind of wander
around these alleys.
But Ying and I are gonna
start heading a little
ways North to some of the other historical
buildings not too far away from here.
Crossing the street in
this area is definitely
not the easiest situation,
but we gotta cross now.
We are in the old historical
heritage area of Jakarta now.
And there is a lot of
traffic in every direction.
We made it to the old area
of Jakarta which is called
Fatahillah which is the
old Dutch colonial area.
There are a lot of heritage
Dutch buildings in this area.
We're now in the big square,
so we're just going to
walk around here for a
little bit and just enjoy
the scenery.
Within this square, a
lot of people are renting
very colorful neon bikes
and just riding around.
And then there a lot of students,
and we met up with a group of students,
and they wanted to ask
some questions about
why we are traveling to Indonesia
and what we like about
traveling to Indonesia.
And then one of the questions
they asked me was why
did you guys come to Indonesia?
And when I told them that
we came to Indonesia to eat,
they all thought that was pretty funny.
I wasn't sure if we were
gonna be able to find
this one street food
snack that I really wanted
to try called kerak telor.
And we happened to find it so we got lucky
and he is making it right now.
It was really genius watching him make it.
What he does is, he
first takes some raw rice
and then puts it into
the bottom of the wok.
And then he really heats up the wok,
heats up that fire, fans the flames.
And then he added a bunch
of different seasonings
including, I know there's some coconut
and probably some salt,
I'm not sure what else.
And then after that he
cracked in egg and then mixed
it all up until it was
like a slushy omelet rice
mixture.
And the true genius of
what he does after that is,
he actually flips the wok over,
so, you would think gravity would make the
entire rice omelet mixture
just fall out of the wok,
but somehow it stays on
the bottom of the wok
even thought it's flipped upside down.
And that's when he really
fans the flames strong
so it's a big fire that
comes up to the bottom
of the wok there and just
kind of scorches that
rice and egg mixture.
And then once it's ready,
he flips it back over,
he scoops it out with a
spatula, adds on some more
seasoning, including a
handful of crispy shallots,
sticks it onto a piece
of paper and it's ready.
This is a street food snack
that definitely has some
history in Indonesia and
I know that it was very
popular since the colonial Dutch times.
And it is truly a genius of a creation.
I'm going to take my first bite.
Wow, that rice, it's like a combination of
a rice and omelet.
And then there is definitely
some coconut in there.
But it's not sweet, just
natural coconut, I think.
Like dried coconut,
it's a little bit crisp.
But that basically just
tastes like a roasted
rice egg omelet.
It tastes like the
bottom of clay pot rice.
The crunchy, kind of
slightly burnt bottom.
So, it has that crispiness,
but then with egg
mixed in and dried coconut.
I'm really happy that we
had a chance to try that
final Jakarta street food.
It's kind of a simple combination,
but I love the way he makes it.
And part of street food and eating snacks
is just enjoying the
atmosphere and watching
them cook the food right before you.
And that is just an absolute
genius of a street food snack.
I think I enjoyed it
more watching the process
of it being made than even eating it.
I think that is gonna be
the end for today's video
about Jakarta street food.
It's been wonderful walking around.
I am just drenched and hot
and sweaty to the core,
so I think we're gonna
jump in a taxi and head
back to our hotel now.
Thank you all very much
for watching this video.
Please remember to give
it a thumbs up if you
enjoyed it and also make
sure you click subscribe
for lots more food videos.
And I'll see you on the next food video.